let's leave america for a little bit and
talk about canada so i know a lot of you
have wanted me to talk about this story
uh and it and it's really breaking right
now and i hope that i can give it a
little bit of a boost because it's
really important and surprise surprise
it's being completely
ignored by mainstream media and i think
you'll know why by the end of this
so we've got some info here from the
daily wire on what's going on in canada
right now a massive convoy of trucks
currently crossing canada which is
protesting against vaccine mandates for
truckers at the canada u.s border as
well as drivers being forced to wear
masks and trucks may prove to be the
longest truck convoy ever recorded the
truckers hope to make it to ottawa
canada's capital by saturday to stage
their protest if the convoy holds
together it could be 10 times larger
than the world record the sun noted
pointing out that guinness states the
trucks are coming from all over and some
estimates have speculated 10 000 trucks
could compromise
the convoy so the the longest uh convoy
of trucks that's ever happened before uh
was from egypt a couple years ago this
looks like it's going to be much much
bigger than that and actually let's uh
show you some video this is over this is
video of over 50 000 canadian truckers
forming a caravan
[Music]
wow this is a huge look at they go
forever this is by accident outside of
edmonton heading into calgary
january 23rd 2022 convoy
more than trucks lots of borrowers and
trucks
very impressive goes on forever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
this is seriously extraordinary stuff
you guys know this canadians aren't
outspoken when's the last time you were
somewhere and it was like those
canadians won't shut up you know when's
the last time a canadian got into a
fight like you have to push a canadian
really far there's not a lot of them
they have a huge amount of space it's
kind of chilly up there like you know
they're usually kind of funny pleasant
people
like they have pushed canadians far
enough 50
000 truckers forming this caravan it's
it's absolutely extraordinary the amount
of people on the roads and it's cold out
there so people out there bringing kids
waving flags uh you know you may
remember that i had maxine bernier on
the show uh probably about two years ago
i think i've had about a few times
actually and i've done some events with
him up in canada and i toured up in
canada with jordan peterson and you know
a lot of libertarian types were coming
to our events and they were always sold
out and uh maxine bernay runs the
people's party of canada and although
they have not done particularly well in
the elections because canada really has
like an even more entrenched
conservative liberal two-party duopoly
than we do
um it's clear that they have that justin
trudeau and these authoritarian lunatics
they've ignited something they've
ignited the spirit of freedom in canada
and this is good
and speaking of good let's talk about
bad here's canadian prime minister
justin trudeau
we know
the way through this pandemic
is by getting everyone vaccinated and
the overwhelming majority close to 90 of
canadians have done exactly that
the
small fringe minority
of people who are on their way to ottawa
or who are
holding unacceptable uh views uh that
they are expressing
do not represent
the views of canadians who have been
there for each other who know
that following the science
and stepping up to protect each other is
the best way to continue to ensure our
freedoms our rights our values as a
country
man what an inauthentic smug
douchebag really first off this thing
where they whisper while they're telling
you briden does this all the time too
you know these people who are very mean
there and we are the nice guys like he
just like you know he like kills kittens
or something like he's just absolutely
awful uh he calls this caravan
of 50 000 truckers and all of their
supporters
which never happens in canada nothing
like this uh they're a fringe minority
right uh he also says that you know
these unvaxed people basically they're
to blame for the pandemic and it's just
like absolute nonsense what this all
started with also was the fact that
these truck drivers just didn't want to
wear masks while they were in their
trucks alone
these people are just
absolutely awful i think we have a
little more video from one of the
caravans right
tomorrow and i just wanted to say best
birthday gift ever having you guys
fighting for us
i am so glad for you truckers you rock
hi my name is matthew i'm 12 years old
and i'm from alberta and i just want to
say
you guys are awesome keep on trucking
good night truckers thank you
to santa canada truckers
i got a little guy here that wants to
say something to the truckers
thank you checkers
hi my name
i'm is years old i come from manitoba i
just wanted to thank you guys
for what you did
i'm praying for you i love you guys hi
my name is aj
and
i'm eight years old and i would just
like to say thank you for all you guys
too
small fringe minority small fringe
minority the kids you're listening to
there obviously uh their folks are
having them call in often on cb radio
just to offer guys some support as
they're getting out there these are good
decent freedom loving people these are
not racists these are not people with
fringe views they don't like trudeau
they don't like authoritarianism they
don't like
mandates
and god bless you guys and anything i
can do to help you i am going to do oh
and just to wrap this up i mentioned at
the top of this story it's like why
aren't you seeing this on cnn why aren't
you seeing this on msnbc was this on the
cover of the new york times today
washington post is it on cnn.com right
now michael would you do that for me
real quick
cnn.com right now let's go to the front
page do they have anything on the front
page of cnn.com a very trusted news
source
nothing he's given me a big no now isn't
that interesting isn't that interesting
this huge revolt in canada
much like it's happening all over
australia and they don't show you that
mainstream media could it possibly be
could it possibly be that the mainstream
media doesn't want you realizing that
you actually have some power over your
life that there's other people like you
out there that the jig is almost up